[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 8 décembre voici le programme 4
collégiens de Trappes sont venus
découvrir les métiers de la justice au
tribunal administratif de Versailles
cette semaine en collaboration avec
l'Académie de Versailles l'objectif est
de montrer que la justice est accessible
à des élèves yvelinois scolarisés en
zone d'éducation prioritaire prochaine
étape les magistrats et les greffiers du
tribunal se déplaceront au sein de la
classe l'association yvelinoise la gerbe
basée à Ecquevilly collaborent depuis
2013 avec le docteur et gynécologue Tony
et Longuet ce dernier a fondé un hôpital
en République démocratique du Congo seul
gynécologue de la région sans courroux
pour 3 millions d'habitants l'accès aux
soins est un défi dans le pays il
présent pour en parler avec nous en
compagnie de Michael pas pour
l'association La Gerbe et puis comme
d'habitude le jeudi à l'approche du
weekend nous vous donnerons nos idées de
sortie dans les Yvelines pièces de
théâtre à Versailles ou encore diffusion
du match des bleus sur écran géant nous
aurons notamment une grande page sur
Noël avec les marchés à venir dans le
département et les activités à faire en
famille à l'approche des fêtes et aussi
dans ce journal nous parlerons également
de la réouverture du musée Lambinet
après trois ans de travaux pour en
parler Émilie Maisonneuve la
conservatrice de ce musée bonsoir
bonsoir alors qu'est-ce qui a changé
après trois ans de travaux on a tout
changé on a tout refait l'intégralité du
musée en fait le parcours a été
entièrement refu donc c'est vraiment un
nouveau musée lambiné qui t'a découvrir
et donc on en parlera plus en détail en
seconde partie d'émission avec nous
également un plateau Michael Païta
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes responsable du
pôle solidarité international de
l'association La Gerbe je le disais à
l'instant depuis 9 ans vos collaborez
avec le docteur et gynécologue Tony est
Longuet et le fruit de cette
collaboration c'est notamment la
construction d'un hôpital en République
démocratique du Congo on reviendra tout
à l'heure sur les actions qui sont
menées sur place mais est-ce que tout
d'abord vous pouvez nous présenter un
petit peu l'association La Gerbe
qu'est-ce que c'est alors l'association
c'est une association de solidarité qui
a commencé avec un volet international
qui s'est pérennisé et puis à partir de
2004 tout un volet d'insertion
professionnelle basée ici dans les
Yvelines et puis petit à petit toute une
dimension de ressourcerie c'est-à-dire
une dimension de réemploi du matériel et
donc ça veut dire qu'on a trois volets
qui sont articulés les armes avec les
autres chaque volet étant au service de
l'autre pour donner une action voilà qui
agit sur le territoire et à
l'international en Europe de l'Est et en
Afrique
de ces actions qui sont menées en
Afrique tout à l'heure dans cette
émission avec nous également les
journalistes de la rédaction de TV 78
bonsoir Grégory canalet vous allez nous
présenter les informations du jour
plusieurs choses au programme on
reviendra sur une visite princière qui a
eu lieu dans les Yvelines on parlera
aussi de ces pommes bio et locales qui
sont mises à disposition des élèves de
Villepreux et enfin on parlera aussi de
la guitare de Marie-Antoinette qui sera
mise aux enchères demain donc ce sera
dans quelques instants Gabriel Gauthier
vous êtes aussi avec nous bonsoir
bonsoir Mathilde vous allez nous
présenter des idées de sortie pour ce
weekend oui pour ce weekend je vous
parlerai d'une idée de sortie au sport
vous en avez parlé dans les titres avec
ce match France - Angleterre qui sera
diffusé sur écran géant à Poissy on
parlera aussi théâtre avec l'adaptation
au Théâtre du roman petit pays on aura
également une exposition et des idées de
sortie dans le thème de Noël bien sûr et
donc ce sera en seconde partie des
missions mais juste avant je vous
propose de jeter un petit coup d'oeil à
la météo de demain
matin le ciel ne devrait être encore
bien nuageux sur l'ensemble du
département au niveau des températures
il fera moins 1 degré avec des moins 3
degrés dans l'après-midi le ciel devrait
se dégager nous devrions avoir quelques
éclaircies au niveau des températures
comptées 2 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie ou
dans et Versailles et 1 degré à
Rambouillet et demain nous prêteront les
pierres tout de suite l'actualité du
jour dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Grégory canalet on
commence par cette information deux
semaines après le meurtre de Djibril une
marche blanche est organisée ce dimanche
entre Coignières et Maurepas
du gymnase du moulin à vent à Coignières
c'est là qui avait éclaté la rixe entre
des jeunes des deux communes dans
laquelle Djibril 14 ans a perdu la vie
le 27 novembre dernier il avait reçu un
violent coup de marteau sur la tête son
meurtrier présumé est toujours en
détention provisoire la marche ira
jusqu'au stade du bois à Maurepas il est
demandé à chaque participant de porter
un t-shirt blanc la municipalité de
Coignières indique par ailleurs que la
circulation rue du moulin à vent sera
interdite dimanche de 13h à 15h on
continue les informations du jour avec
une visite princière dans les Yvelines
le prince Albert II de Monaco s'est
rendu à Médan hier mercredi la visiter
le musée Dreyfus inauguré il y a un peu
plus d'un an juste à côté de la maison
Zola ou vivait Émile Zola un déplacement
dans la plus stricte intimité sur place
seulement la délégation monégasque qui
ne vingtaine d'invités à trier sur le
volet très peu d'images aussi pour le
moment à part ces deux clichés qui sont
partagés par nos confrères du Parisien
alors pourquoi cette visite du
prince en Grégory par cette visite il a
voulu Ino il a voulu honorer la mémoire
de son arrière arrière grand-père Albert
1er mort il y a 100 ans qui avait
soutenu Alfred Dreyfus au moment de la
célèbre affaire qui porte son nom Albert
1er était convaincu de l'innocence de
l'officier français accusé et inculper
pour haute trahison grâce à son statut
principe appelé pour le capitaine à deux
reprises auprès du président de la
République de l'époque Félix Faure il a
même accueilli à Monaco des dreyfusards
en leur attribuant des fonctions au
palais pour l'image du jour Mathilde
direction Villepreux des pommes bio et
villes prozienne livrées ce matin à la
cuisine centrale de la commune depuis un
mois la municipalité s'approvisionne
auprès de la ferme de la haie pour sa
restauration collective environ 7000
pommes sont commandées par mois elles
sont servis sur les plateaux repas des
écoliers des résidents d'un foyer pour
personnes âgées et aussi pour le portage
des repas du jus de pomme sera également
servi à l'occasion des événements de la
ville un partenariat gagnant-gagnant
pour la ville de Villepreux c'est
d'acheter en direct sans immédiaire et
ça réduit les coûts et pour
l'arboriculteur l'avantage c'est
découler sa production en écoute les
interviews collectées au micro de Julien
le roi c'est l'essentiel quoi développer
le cas le local ultra local là pour les
livraisons on met deux minutes à venir
que demander de plus quoi quand on parle
du coup de l'énergie pour les livraisons
du coup des livreurs etc etc bon bah là
moi je suis je suis satisfait à 100% si
je pouvais tout livré dans un rayon de
de 3 km je serai je serai le plus
heureux des arbresiculteurs avec cet
approvisionnement de pommes auprès d'un
arboriculteur de Villepreux et bien je
dirais qu'on coche toutes les cases en
fait on a des fruits de saison de grande
qualité donc gustativement c'est
vraiment extraordinaire les enfants nous
le disent ils les apprécient énormément
ce sont des pommes savoureuses comment
dire avec une
fine enfin vraiment avec un bon calibre
donc ça c'est vraiment formidable pour
la ville c'est une manière aussi
d'entamer une démarche
d'approvisionnement en direct auprès de
nos de nos producteurs
ça donne envie de goûter tout ça Grégory
effectivement et le chiffre du jour il y
en a même deux c'est 60 000 et 80000
pourquoi fourchette du prix estimée de
la guitare de Marie-Antoinette elle
vaudrait entre 60000 et 80000 euros
l'instrument de musique sera mis aux
enchères ce vendredi par la maison agüte
à Neuilly-sur-Seine il a appartenu cet
instrument de musique à la reine de
France féru de musique qui jouait à
organiser des concerts au Petit Trianon
ça résidence à Versailles elle a guitare
conçue en 1775 par le luthier Michelot
aurait été offerte à la Marquise de la
roche-lambert thévalès l'une des plus
proches confidentes de Marie-Antoinette
elle a été conservée ensuite à travers
les génération au sein de la famille de
la marquise un rendez-vous à présent lié
à l'orientation c'est le forum des
métiers du patrimoine et de l'artisanat
d'excellence au campus de Versailles si
vous êtes collégien lycéen ou même
étudiant et que vous êtes intéressé par
l'artisanat il est fait pour vous ce
rendez-vous l'événement s'est ouvert
aujourd'hui il va se poursuivre jusqu'à
dimanche au grandes écuries sur place
une cinquantaine d'écoles d'artisans et
d'entreprises l'entrée est gratuite et
libre c'est de 9h à 18h30 ce vendredi et
de 10h à 18h samedi et dimanche et si
vous loupez ce forum Mathilde pas
d'inquiétude il y en aura d'autres
proposés en février et en mars et vous
souhaitiez Grégory terminer par une
autre information le préservatif sera
gratuit en pharmacie pour tous les
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans annonce en fin
d'après-midi du président de la
République Emmanuel Macron lors d'une
session et du Conseil national de la
refondation qui se tenait aujourd'hui
dans la Vienne une gratuité qui a
interviendra à partir du 1er janvier
prochain merci beaucoup Grégory canalet
et si vous aussi comme d'habitude vous
voyez une information qui vous a marqué
près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous
la partager en utilisant le hashtag 7
et une autre journaliste de la rédaction
de tv78 nous a rejoint un plateau Régine
rallès bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes semaine
le tribunal administratif de Versailles
a accueilli 4 élèves de 3e des élèves du
collège Gustave Courbet de Trappes le
but faire découvrir les métiers de la
justice alors oui Mathilde on va en
parler mais tout d'abord j'aimerais
faire un petit tour de table est-ce que
l'un d'entre vous pourrait m'expliquer
ce qu'est un tribunal administratif
alors je pense que comme son nom
l'indique il règle des litiges liées à
l'administration avec des
administrations oui vous avez d'autres
idées
dans le juridique
écoutez alors voici une définition très
claire qui s'affiche à l'écran donc le
tribunal administratif juge les litiges
entre les particuliers et les
administration donc par administration
on entend état collectivités
territoriale établissement public ou
organisme privé chargé d'une mission de
service public bon Mathilde n'était pas
très loin non c'est vrai alors cette
semaine la semaine de stage était
organisée autre par le tribunal
administratif et l'académie de
Versailles dans le cadre du parcours
citoyen ce qui permet aux élèves des
collèges des Yvelines classées REP donc
réseau éducation prioritaire
alors excusez-moi
découvrir des métiers de la juridiction
administrative et même de susciter des
vocations donc durant cette semaine les
élèves ont pu assister à des audiences
de chambre de référé et d'urgence
étrangers on écoute tout de suite Amina
l'une des stagiaires au micro de Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude je pensais pas que ça
allait être aussi bien
ça a vraiment stage parce que en fait
j'ai apprends des choses et en même
temps je pensais que ça allait être
stressant et très carré en fait pas du
tout on rigole on travaille on travaille
on s'amusant et ça nous améliore quoi
cette semaine s'achèvera demain donc
vendredi 9 décembre mais cela constitue
la première étape la deuxième étape se
fera au printemps cette fois-ci des
greffiers et d'autres avocats se
déplaceront dans les classes des élèves
accueillies en stage pour présenter les
métiers de la juridiction donc on a
entendu une des stagiaires mais pourquoi
le tribunal se prête au jeu on écoute
l'interview de génie rendez nous la
présidente du tribunal administratif de
Versailles
[Musique]
je suis du quotidien ça leur parle on
leur a fait à la troisième
étape l'an dernier on leur a fait un
dossier on a une audience fictive sur
une histoire de trichotback donc ces
choses-là ça va au tribunal
administratif donc c'est quand même
assez parlant pour eux
et puis je crois qu'il est important que
justement il comprenne que la justice
est quelque chose d'accessible c'est un
outil pour eux c'est pas une institution
sur un nez dont il faut avoir peur et
c'est vraiment leur apprentissage de
citoyens c'est pour ça qu'on a appelé ça
parcours citoyen
[Musique]
premier contact avec eux ça a été de
leur donner quelques éléments de langage
parce que mais après je pense que c'est
partout pareil tous les élèves qui font
un stage de 3e dans toute univers
professionnel il y a des abréviations il
y a des termes
particuliers après on n'est pas là pour
faire deux des magistrats peut-être que
ce sera le cas de certains si j'ai mon
réfère à certaines lettres de motivation
il y en a qui ont envie d'être avocat
parce que c'est des enfants motivés qui
viennent ils ont ils ont fait l'objet
d'une sélection alors je sais pas
exactement comment au sein de leur
établissement
et
ils vont d'ailleurs aussi rencontrer un
avocat mais on leur montre qu'il y a
aussi d'autres métiers dans cette
tribunal il y a l'accueil il y a
l'informatique il y a le courrier il y a
les archives il y a agent de greffe en
fait c'est des personnes dans un
tribunal c'est pas c'est pas une
institution désincarnée
[Musique]
c'est le droit c'est un élément
fondateur de notre pacte social et il
est de notre devoir je pense qu'on doit
être exemplaire dans nos
institutions de justice de leur rendre
accessible au plus grand nombre
[Musique]
la troisième étape pour a lieu à la fin
de l'année judiciaire c'est-à-dire en
juin les élèves signifieront un jeu de
rôle où il reproduiront un procès fictif
merci beaucoup Régine rallès vous en
parliez hier dans les informations du
jour mardi 6 décembre a eu lieu une
expérience atypique une partie de tennis
entre recruteurs et jeunes issus de
quartiers prioritaires avant un job
dating l'objectif permet des échanges
dans un cadre moins formel et faire
tomber les clichés pour faciliter la
phase de recrutement l'opération est
nommée faite le mur le reportage de
Julien Leroy
jouer au tennis avec son recruteur juste
avant son entretien d'embauche un
concept original vécu par ses 30 jeunes
ici de quartiers prioritaires lors du
jeu 7 et job se mardi 6 décembre
organisé pour la première fois attrape
par l'association faites le mur de
Yannick Noah cet événement a permis de
rassembler une dizaine d'entreprises
c'est un concept de Job Dating en fait
directement sur le tennis afin de
désacraliser le recrutement de
déstresser un peu les jeunes ça crée un
lien direct qui est plus facile ou
directement le recruteur et le jeûne se
parle sur le terrain on parlait de
salaire de de comment ça se passe au
niveau du travail s'il y a des jours de
repos à particulier
je trouve que c'est une méthode très
innovante qui permet aussi de briser la
glace auprès donc de ces candidats
aujourd'hui il faut aller au devant des
candidats il fallait les chercher au
plus près de chez eux donc je pense que
le sport aussi permet de mieux prendre
contact avec eux et puis voilà de
faciliter la communication
après un moment sportif l'ambiance est
devenue plus formelle dans ce cadre
atypique table posée à même le terrain
pour le job dating des postes autour des
métiers de la climatisation de la
mécanique ou encore de l'armée était
proposée pour moi c'est super important
de participer au job dating parce que je
suis à la recherche d'un emploi je peux
en CDI soit en restauration en commerce
en garde d'enfant ça permet aussi de se
faire connaître auprès des jeunes
puisque moi je travaille pour une agence
d'intérim et on se rend compte que les
jeunes connaissent de moins en moins le
monde de l'intérim donc c'est vrai que
c'est important aussi de se faire
connaître quelques barrières en fait des
deux côtés ça lève des barrières
peut-être un peu désappréhensions de la
part du jeûne déjà du gène envers le
recruteur c'est peut-être des fois un
monde qui est pas forcément atteignable
mais aussi de la part du recruteur
envers le jeûne qui a peut-être pas la
bonne image des jeunes de quartier on a
mon certain de ces demandeurs d'emploi
étaient formés à la prise de parole en
public à travers des simulations
d'entretien et des perfectionnement à
l'oral présente dans toute la France
l'association faite le mur intervient
chaque année auprès de 13000
bénéficiaires
on en parlait en début d'émission
l'association La Gerbe collaborent
depuis 2013 avec le docteur Tony et
Longuet qui est avec nous en plateau ce
soir bonsoir
vous êtes gynécologue et également le
fondateur de l'hôpital haut-tema qui se
trouve en République démocratique du
Congo vous êtes aussi le seul
gynécologue de la région sans courroux
qui regroupe 3 millions d'habitants il y
a également une école un orphelinat pour
tout ça vous collaborez avec
l'association La Gerbe Michael vous êtes
représentant de cette association
comment est-ce qu'elle est née cette
collaboration entre entre vous deux
alors ben écoutez en tout cas en 2013 un
petit peu avant cela le docteur est
languette était venu en France était en
France depuis déjà un petit moment pour
se spécialiser puisque ça spécialisation
a été faite en gynécologie ici en France
et à cette occasion il était déjà dans
cette posture d'initiative pour sa
région et il était en recherche de
collaborateurs il est venu nous exposer
la situation qui était critique on peut
le dire et les besoins qui avaient et on
est emboîté le pas et on regrette pas
puisque aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de
choses à dire sur tout ce qui a été fait
vous êtes le seul centre de soins
spécialités spécialisés de la région
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer en
quoi l'accès aux soins est compliqué
dans cette région alors il faut
seulement dire que la région du sankoro
c'est une grande région de 100 et 9000
km². ce qui représente justement neuf
fois l'île de France et deux fois trois
fois la Suisse donc c'est vraiment une
région dans un pays
alors un pays dans un pays bien entendu
alors c'est une région mais qui est tout
à fait enclavée parce que les routes
sont pratiquement impraticables donc on
n'a pas des routes et puis l'accès aux
soins
parait assez difficile pour tout le
monde et alors donc moi quand je suis
revenu et je suis venu en France et je
suis rentré et pour pouvoir aider je
suis le seul spécialiste en gynécologie
pour aider vraiment l'accès à la santé
aux femmes vous avez aidé combien de
femmes environ alors jusque là donc à
partir du moment où nous avons mis en
place cette hôpital nous avons déjà
opéré plus de
1200 femmes avec des interventions
chirurgicales majeures on a y a à faire
accoucher plus de
23000 femmes et on a opéré
des pathologies assez assez spéciales
comme les fistule chez les femmes plus
de 300 ans et donc il y a plusieurs
pôles on va dire au à l'hôpital vous
avez notamment une clinique juridique
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus
juridique bien entendu parce que comme
vous savez le Congo c'est un pays qui
est en guerre à tout temps en guerre et
à cette guerre à l'est du pays une
guerre qui ne se termine pas et pendant
que pendant il y a la dépendance qui a
la guerre il y a justement des viols qui
sont faites à la femme et ces femmes qui
viennent chez nous violenter déjà
présente de de pathologies présentes des
fistules et nous nous prenons en charge
ces femmes de façon physique et aussi de
façon juridique même sociale aussi c'est
à dire que on les traite et puis avec la
clinique juridique on a des avocats on a
de policiers qui sont sur place et qui
vont interpeller les auteurs pour
pouvoir justement les décourager et vous
aider aussi ces femmes psychologiquement
tout à fait on a on a mis en place un
bureau pour la prise en charge des
psychologique c'est à dire que sa femme
qui sont violets sont un peu ont des
problèmes aussi psychologiques et nous
avons pensé mettre ce bureau sur place
et pour aider ces femmes sur le plan
psychologique bien entendu et important
aussi vous aider ces femmes à trouver
des nouveaux métiers des nouvelles
occupations on peut dire ça comme ça oui
tout à fait parce que ce sont ces femmes
là la plupart de ces femmes sont des
femmes qui sont démunis et comme elles
sont démunis et puis au-delà de du fait
que les soins démunis et de son violet
et le père de vraiment
l'aspect des femmes c'est comme ça que
voilà on s'est dit si on leur apprend un
métier on leur donne une occasion de
pouvoir se réintégrer dans la société
ces femmes là trouvent quand même
vraiment leur vie sociale en quelque
sorte il y a combien de personnes qui
travaillent dans cet hôpital nous avons
plus de 500 en 50 employés
l'objectif futur c'est de l'agrandir
encore l'objectif est futur c'est parce
que c'est parmi les au fait il est le
seul hôpital qui est bien équipé dans la
province et l'objectif essaie de faire
en sorte que cet hôpital puisse répondre
recommandations nationales
d'une structure médicale qui peut avoir
plus de de 300 litres et vous êtes
tourné vers le futur puisque dans cette
dans cet hôpital il y a également un une
école pour former les futurs médecins et
infirmières voilà donc nous avons mis en
place une université et une université
parce qu'on a compris que les les
infirmiers qui travaillent avec nous
n'était pas assez capables de pouvoir
répondre à ce à ces grands à ces gros
problèmes de santé on a pensé formé des
infirmiers qui sont capables qui seront
capables de pouvoir travailler aussi
bien l'hôpital que notre hôpital bien
entendu hôpital mais aussi dans les
autres hôpitaux de la région
et alors Michael bighta vous vous
souvenez avec l'association La Gerbe
toutes ces actions et vous allez mettre
en place en janvier une course connectée
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
que c'est oui alors il y a un événement
qui s'appelle op360 qui réunit une
vingtaine de ONG qui chacune vont
présenter un projet qu'ils soutiennent
nous on a décidé de cette année soutenir
une vingtaine d'étudiants qui justement
suivent le cursus d'infirmier dans cet
université ces étudiants qui ont la
situation particulière d'être orphelin
et en plus avoir charge de famille c'est
à dire ils ont des frères et soeurs qui
doivent s'occuper et donc ils ont une
situation particulièrement complexe pour
pouvoir accéder aux études et donc on va
lancer l'objectif de pouvoir parrainer
20 de ces étudiants à travers cette
course donc cette course connectée elle
va commencer déjà en fait demain le site
internet de la course commence il y a
ensuite les gens pourront à distance
pouvoir participer à l'événement et il y
aura le 15 avril sur la base de loisirs
des Mureaux Verneuil une journée festive
où tous les participants pourront se
retrouver pour célébrer cette cette fin
d'événements le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de notre écran pourquoi
c'est important pour l'association La
Gerbe de collaborer de participer à ces
actions alors en tout cas il faut se
rendre compte de l'ampleur du défi que
représente la tâche à laquelle s'est
attaqué le docteur est Longuet il faut
dire que peu ou pas de personnes se
lanceraient un tel défi lorsqu'on est
devant une montagne est-ce qu'on va se
lancer l'idée de pouvoir la faire
descendre comme ça et c'est le défi qui
s'est proposé de relever et qu'il relève
bien puisqu'il y a une vraie différence
qui est faite depuis qu'il se met en
marche et donc nous on marche à ses
côtés par de l'envoi de matériel par des
collectes de fonds pour pouvoir vraiment
faire levier sur les actions qu'il mène
en place et cette capacité de mobiliser
aussi les gens
au niveau du terrain et faire la
différence
savoir quels sont les Francs aujourd'hui
vous le dites aujourd'hui la situation
notamment en termes de guerre en
République démocratique du Congo c'est
c'est l'un des principaux freins il y en
a d'autres aujourd'hui voilà donc
d'abord ça d'abord le fait qu'il y a
cette guerre là qui sévit avec le prix
d'élection à l'est de la République
démocratique du Congo c'était guère là
fait que la tension des autorités sur
place soit tournée vers là plutôt que
vers le développement de de la région
c'est comme ça que la région est très
enclavie et n'est pas beaucoup
développée c'est vraiment parmi les
éléments qui sont qui sont à la base
donc Michael Petel association la gerbe
soutient d'autres initiatives
internationales vous soutenez également
des habitants
Ukrainiens en envoyant aussi du matériel
oui tout à fait alors nous on collabore
avec l'Ukraine depuis 2009 en fait on a
désiré aller plus loin parce que on
était déjà inscrit dans cette démarche
là depuis déjà 2014 avec la garde dans
le don de base orienté du matériel à la
fois vers les déplacer internes ou vers
les personnes dans le don-basse sont
distinction évidemment de politique ou
autre c'est pas notre propos et puis en
2022 évidemment avec le conflit qui a
éclaté on a intensifié énormément notre
nos envois on a multiplié par 3 les
volumes habituels avec lesquels on
fonctionné et encore en cette fin
d'année alors c'est plus difficile parce
qu'évidemment l'élan de générosité et on
le comprend très bien ses souffles c'est
normal ben nous il faut qu'on continue à
travailler en tout cas pour continuer à
collecter dans cette période d'hiver où
les choses deviennent plus critiques
encore on ne sait et bien merci Michael
Païta et docteur Tony est Longuet d'être
venu en parler en plateau avec nous si
vous souhaitez faire un don ou
participer vous pouvez le faire sur le
site internet de Hop
360.fr qui s'affiche juste en dessous
cette semaine nous vous avons proposé
une série de reportages sur le chef
cuisinier Jérémy en bielle du restaurant
de l'Arche durant les trois premiers
épisodes nous l'avons suivi chez ses
producteurs et éleveurs préférés du pays
oudanais et aujourd'hui dans cet épisode
final le chef vous dévoile sa recette de
poule au pot on regarde tout de suite le
reportage de Nicolas dandry
bon je suis venu chercher les poules de
Houdan pour pouvoir faire la poule au
pot
alors on essaie de bien garder les
critères de beauté donc faut bien là
houpette après faut pas trop de noir pas
trop de blanc
c'est bien de voir justement que il y a
des personnes comme toi qui qui
travaillent sur sur la continuité du
d'une poule comme la poule dedans qui
aujourd'hui est difficile à élever
[Musique]
on va réaliser la recette de la de la
poule au pot donc la poule au pot tout
simplement c'est une volaille qui va
être pochée et qui va être farci avec
une farce là aujourd'hui à base de veau
et des petits légumes de saisonnalité
pour la farce j'ai du veau haché du
persil des œufs bio des échalotes les
abats de la poule de Boudon de la crème
liquide et après tout ce qui va être
garniture aromatique les oignons les
clous de girofle et les légumes qui
seront à consommer avec la poule au pot
carottes n'avait et poireaux
je vais réaliser en premier lieu la
farce du haché de veau je vais y
rajouter ma crème liquide
mon persil haché mes échalotes ciselées
[Musique]
mes abats hachés aussi
mes œufs
et après on a l'axe le tout pour faire
notre farce
donc on utilise du veau parce que c'est
levé au lait et faut savoir que la poule
de Houdan elle est finie aussi au lait
donc l'association des deux produits se
marient très bien
[Musique]
qu'on va la remettre et après il faut
pas hésiter à la laisser reposer au
moins une heure vraiment pour tous les
aromates
prennent bien le goût au niveau du veau
maintenant on va s'attaquer à la
garniture de notre poule au pot
donc moi j'aime bien laisser des gros
morceaux donc c'est les légumes qui vont
nous servir à parfumer le bouillon
qui vont prendre toutes les saveurs de
la volaille donner leur saveur à la
volaille
[Musique]
donc là il s'est passé une heure de
temps et maintenant on va tout
simplement
remplir notre poule de Houdan
et après je vais venir tout simplement
la brider pour éviter que la farce
ressort pendant le pochage
le but c'est pas de faire de la haute
couture le but c'est vraiment de faire
en sorte que ce soit
ce soit fermé
et maintenant on a plus qu'à mettre tout
dans un bouillon avec les légumes les
aromates le sel le poivre notre vin
blanc et notre poule de Houdan et on
attend maintenant au moins 8 heures
[Musique]
et justement à Nicolas d'André nous a
rejoint en plateau bonsoir alors un
retour sur ce reportage qu'est-ce qui
vous a marqué déjà la durée parce que
c'est quand même quatre épisodes qu'on a
découvert tout au long de la semaine
donc une petite série on n'a pas
vocation à devenir une plateforme de
streaming comme vous connaître mais
voilà une petite série à l'échelle de TV
78 mais donc durée de tournage quand
même on a commencé à 7h30 on était tous
les deux Mathilde on a commencé à 7h30
du matin jusqu'à 15h l'après-midi
différentes séquences découvertes du
territoire des Yvelines du pays oudanais
entre Houdan Richebourg jusqu'à Londres
à la limite du nord du département des
Yvelines a découvert de tous ces
producteurs et puis ce chef restaurateur
jérémy obiac a eu des difficultés il a
connu quelques difficultés de la vie et
qui a su rebondir et qui aujourd'hui ben
voilà à son restaurant cuisine pour les
gens avec des produits locaux en circuit
court il se fournit autour de chez lui
dans un périmètre aller de 10 15 km et
voilà ce qu'on peut faire comme type de
reportage sur TV 78 grâce à ces
personnes là quoi voilà et alors est-ce
que ça vous a donné envie de goûter
cette du plateau ah bah oui ça donne
envie ça peut être un petit plat à
mettre sur la table de Noël peut-être
avec un produit local exactement et puis
alors faut savoir qu'elle n'est pas
encore à sa carte parce que Julien Lecoq
on a découvert hier le producteur de la
poule de Houdan à longues est en train
de lancer de relancer un élevage de
poules de Houdan donc peut-être qu'elle
sera à la carte l'été le printemps
prochain on était 2023 voilà en tout cas
mathilde a bien apprécié la poule de
Houdan c'était très bon effectivement je
vous propose de passer maintenant à
cette page loisir
[Musique]
depuis le samedi 3 décembre le musée
Lambinet situé à Versailles à rouvert
ses portes au public après des travaux
durant trois ans alors Émilie
Maisonneuve vous êtes la conservatrice
de ce musée qu'avez-vous fait comme
travaux qu'est-ce qui a été changé alors
on a changé un terme entièrement le
parcours c'est à dire que l'intégralité
des 35 salles et des trois niveaux ont
été repeints scénographie changer
on a complètement varié en fait le
propos voilà pour un propos beaucoup
plus lisible et puis on a édité un
nouveau guide des collections aussi et
du coup qu'est-ce qu'on peut découvrir
ou redécouvrir comme œuvre alors
l'oeuvre phare vous parlez tout à
l'heure d'un luthier qui travaille pour
Marie-Antoinette c'est une harpe qui a
été réalisée par le luthier justement de
Marie-Antoinette le luthier principal
donc en fait c'est une harpe du 18e
siècle des années
1786-87 et qui en fait une sorte de
prototype avec 8 pédales et la
particularité c'est qu'on l'a restauré
pour pouvoir en jouer donc on fera des
concerts privilégier de temps en temps
avec cette harpe qui a un son très très
particulier et qui vraiment redonne vie
à ce 18ème siècle qu'on illustre très
bien au musée lambda et également des
peintures des sculptures c'est très
compliqué c'est très compliqué parce
qu'en fait on est un musée de
collectionneur donc le principe c'est
que des donateurs depuis le 19e siècle
en fait on fait le choix de donner leurs
œuvres au musée Lambinet donnés ou légué
donc on a un ensemble très varié en
effet en termes de beaux-arts qui va du
16ème siècle au 19e siècle pour la
partie principale on a aussi des
éléments du 20e siècle mais un petit peu
moins courant et donc en fait on
présente de manière beaucoup plus
organisée avec les peintures 18e
peinture 19e les objets d'art qu'on a
vraiment remis en valeur ça c'était
vraiment notre propos principal c'était
de ne plus les montrer comme des faire
valoir mais vraiment comme des œuvres à
part entière et dans une scénographie
beaucoup plus théâtrale aussi
qu'auparavant et donc ce musée n'existe
depuis
90 ans en quoi en fait c'est un symbole
pour la pour la ville de Versailles ce
musée on est vraiment en effet le musée
d'art et d'histoire de la ville de
Versailles donc pour beaucoup de
Français voilà ils connaissent le rôle
de Versailles durant l'Ancien Régime et
on a été aussi à des moments importants
de l'histoire la Révolution les années
licence une ville majeure en fait dans
l'histoire de France donc notre notre
propos est de parler de l'histoire de la
ville mais liée à l'histoire de France
et puis de montrer justement la richesse
des artistes et artisans qui ont
travaillé pour pour la ville tout
particulièrement pendant l'installation
de la Cour dans notre dans notre ville
Grégory vous aviez une question
peut-être une certaine forme
d'impatience pendant ces trois ans de
travaux c'était important pour peut-être
lui donner 90 ans de plus tout ce qu'on
peut lui souhaiter au musée Lambinet
même davantage on travaille un peu pour
pour l'éternité parce qu'on est un musée
musée de France donc toutes les œuvres
faites qui sont dans notre dans notre
inventaire dans notre fond font partie
du patrimoine condamnation donc c'est
notre rôle de les conserver en effet
trois ans c'était long mais on a eu
aussi la période covid qui finalement
était pour nous une opportunité en fait
d'aller beaucoup plus loin dans les
travaux et puis aujourd'hui on est très
très heureux évidemment de retrouver de
retrouver le public enfant Nicolas
comment vous articulez aussi avec le
château de Versailles forcément les on
peut imaginer les touristes qui viennent
de l'étranger pensent directement à
aller au château de Versailles comment
vous travaillez avec le château de
Versailles pour peut-être aussi venir
découvrir votre musée à vous et les
oeuvres que vous avez alors en fait on a
des des échanges avec eux on leur prête
des oeuvres ils nous prennent des œuvres
on a des oeuvres en dépôt d'ailleurs qui
qui sont accepté de déposer pour le
nouveau musée et puis l'idée c'est en
fait d'être plutôt axé nous sur une
visite
conviviale une visite aussi dans un
certain confort le château de Versailles
c'est beaucoup une visite de célébration
il faut absolument avoir vu le château
de Versailles et nous on va chercher
plutôt à tirer un public familial un
public francilien et puis un public
actif parce qu'on va souhaite mener des
visites un peu particulières des visites
relaxation
œnologie voilà pour essayer un petit peu
de d'attirer ce public actif qu'on
espère avoir en soirée et le week-end et
donc cette année vous allez fêter vos 90
ans est-ce que vous avez préparé quelque
chose vous avez prévu quelque chose
alors on a fait en fait souffler les
bougies au musée au mois de juin alors
quand c'était encore fermé mais l'idée
en effet c'est de pouvoir utiliser cette
première année pour lancer toute une
nouvelle programmation des événements
des visites théâtralisées et je pense
qu'à l'occasion essentiellement de la
Nuit des Musées prochaine donc ce sera
en 2023 ce sera l'idée voilà de marquer
le coup à nouveau pour célébrer un peu
en retard cette anniversaire donc une
programmation qu'on pourra connaître
prochainement oui alors on a tout un
système de communication avec évidemment
les réseaux sociaux on est très actif
sur sur les réseaux et donc vous pouvez
suivre toutes toutes les nouvelles
propositions qui sont faites pour tous
les âges et pour toutes les populations
et bien merci beaucoup Emilie
Maisonneuve d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et d'être venu un plateau je
le rappelle vous êtes la conservatrice
du musée l'embinet situé à Versailles et
si vous ne savez pas quoi faire ce
week-end vous pouvez découvrir ou
redécouvrir ce musée ce week-end
peut-être et quelque chose me dit que si
vous êtes aussi à court d'idées Gabriel
vous avez prévu des idées de sortie pour
noter les spectateurs et oui tout à fait
Mathilde on commence avec l'événement de
ce weekend pour les fans de sport
l'équipe de France affronte l'Angleterre
samedi soir pour les quarts de finale de
Coupe du monde alors la ville de Poissy
propose la diffusion du match sur écran
géant au forum Armand Peugeot à la clé
de cette rencontre une place en
demi-finale vous le savez rendez vous
donc à 20h pour le coup d'envoi et
plutôt dans la journée le Maroc
affrontera le Portugal alors on sait que
vous êtes nombreux dans les Yvelines à
soutenir ces deux équipes on vous attend
en Story sur notre compte Instagram et
Facebook TV 78 pour un petit sondage
qu'on vous a préparé pour se connaître
l'équipe que vous supportez alors à 18h
sachez que
74% de nos abonnés supporter le Maroc et
36 le Portugal je sais pas autour de la
table les Portugais sont nombreux à la
communauté portugaise et nombreuses
partout même dans les Yvelines donc ils
ont intérêts aller mettre qu'il supporte
le Portugal il faut égaliser et puis en
plus le gagnant de ce match affrontera
peut-être l'équipe de France il qualifie
contre l'Angleterre
pour ceux qui sont
fan de sport Gabriel vous avez
pris d'autres sorties un peu plus
culturelles oui jusqu'à samedi soir de
20h30 à 22h30 le théâtre montentier de
Versailles propose la pièce petit pays
alors cette pièce elle est inspirée du
roman éponyme de Gael Faye elle retrace
l'histoire d'un bourrindais dont
l'entrée dans l'adolescence est marquée
par le début du génotype génocide des
Tutsi au Rwanda pays voisins on assiste
au passage de l'insouciance de l'enfance
à la prise de conscience de
l'adolescence parmi les thématiques qui
seront abordées dans cette pièce on
parlera de l'histoire coloniale le
racisme mais aussi le partage des
frontières qui a été imposée au peuple
africain et on reste dans les sorties
culturelles puisque vous nous avez
sélectionné une exposition à
Clairefontaine oui si vous avez envie de
vous réchauffer un peu et de voyager je
vous conseille l'exposition plein feu
elle est dédiée à l'ambiguïté de l'astre
solaire c'est une exposition lumineuse
et colorée qui nous interroge sur notre
rapport au monde engageant une réflexion
sur nos modes de vie notamment alors
vous avez jusqu'à dimanche pour en
profiter ensuite il y aura une pause et
l'exposition reprendra le 7 janvier 2023
et ce jusqu'au 29 janvier les vacances
de Noël approchent à grands pas et c'est
le dernier week-end pour profiter du
Noël décalé à la Commanderie oui toute
la journée la commanderie de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines vous propose
un moment festif parmi toutes les choses
à faire vous pourrez profiter d'un
marché d'associations solidaire et de
créateurs locaux vous pourrez également
profiter d'activité de création et ou
encore de déguster des spécialités en
sécurité vous aimez ça vous avez
tendance à aimer ça autour de la table
des spécialités afro caribben je vais y
arriver cuisiner
et alors que serait ces fêtes de fin
d'année sans patinoire Gabriel oui vous
pourrez patiner à Élancourt
Maisons-Laffitte ou Maurepas carrière
sous Poissy ne fait pas exception le
village de Noël
est accompagné d'une piste de glisse
vous pourrez en profiter jusqu'au 30
décembre
est-ce que vous avez une sortie
le football on est tous les deux grandes
fun de sport fan de sport fan de sport
avant tout et oui forcément les quarts
de finale de cette Coupe du Monde nous
attire mais j'ai toujours pas fait mes
cadeaux de Noël donc pourquoi pas aller
faire un petit tour à la Commanderie
faire des dégustations
et si vous souhaitez continuer dans
cette ambiance de Noël il y a toujours
les marchés de Noël dans les Yvelines
qui sont en cours on commence à plaisir
les festivités auront lieu au Parc du
Château et se dès vendredi soir et
l'encours organise également son
événement pendant 3 jours sur le parvis
de l'Hôtel de Ville a Guyancourt ce sera
un marché solidaire pour la ville
jumelée de Comé au Bénin rendez-vous à
la Maison de l'environnement pour le
marché de Noël de Magny né à Meaux et à
la place des justes pour celui de
Saint-Cyr l'école à Maurepas est au
gymnase de La malmedonne que vous
pourrez profiter de plusieurs animations
dès vendredi soir un voisin le
Bretonneux le marché de Noël se tiendra
au Centre sportif les pyramides et pour
la semaine prochaine ce sont les
communes des clés sous bois et de
Trappes qui installeront leur marché de
Noël pour les clés sous bois rendez vous
à l'espace Philippe Noiret pour trap le
marché se tiendra à toute la semaine du
16 au 23 décembre sur la place de la
Merise et d'ici là les fêtes de fin
d'année il est possible pour les petits
des Yvelines mais aussi pour tout court
de déposer leurs lettres au Père Noël
Nicolas est-ce que vous avez déposé
votre lettre
la mairie d'épônes à ma lettre donc
j'espère que la mairie d'épaule
l'enverra comme il se doit au Papa Noël
pour les autres communes plusieurs
plusieurs boîtes aux lettres sont à
disposition n'hésitez pas à vous
renseigner sur le site Internet de la
mairie à Plaisir la boîte aux lettres
est situé dans le parc de l'Hôtel de
Ville à Maurepas sur la place Charles de
Gaulle pour maniller les mots aller dans
le hall de l'Hôtel de Ville a Guyancourt
la boîte est installée sur le parvis de
l'Hôtel de Ville attention postez bien
votre lettre avant le 15 décembre pour
Poissy c'est sur la place de la
République à Rambouillet le lien avec le
Pôle Nord restera établi jusqu'au 24
décembre la boîte aux lettres permettra
au rambolitain de déposer également des
cartes ou des dessins qui seront ensuite
distribués aux personnes âgées attention
à bien indiquer sur vos lettres Père
Noël pôle Nord ainsi que votre adresse
pour avoir une réponse et comme
d'habitude le jeudi Nicolas d'André vous
nous avez préparer un petit quiz c'est
sur quel thème cette semaine on va
parler des espaces commerciaux puisque
vous savez le papa noël est en train de
parcourir ces espaces commerciaux des
Yvelines et parcours l'ensemble des
centres commerciaux et donc on va
redécouvrir un peu les centres
commerciaux on va faire un voyage dans
le temps maintenant depuis la semaine
dernière on utilise les archives donc je
suis allé chercher dans les archives
première question nous sommes le 6
décembre 2008 et regarder cet extrait
d'un reportage réalisé à l'époque sur la
pose d'une première pierre regardez
une première pierre pour
si le chantier est déjà bien avancé ce
pôle commercial marquera une nouvelle
ère pour la ville connue surtout pour
ses magasins implantés anarchiquement le
long de la RN10
excusez-moi pour le bip hein parce qu'il
y avait la réponse forcément alors à
votre avis la première pierre concerne
quel espace commercial actuel j'ai
reconnu moi sur les images l'ancien
maire de Coignières Henri Payet donc je
dirais que c'est ta Coignières et
pourquoi pas
son commercial des portes de Chevreuse
réponse bravo Grégory la réponse va
s'afficher à l'écran effectivement les
portes de chevreuses à Coignières voilà
avec l'espace commercial des portes de
choses situées à côté du forum JB à côté
de Maurepas finalement et donc on sait
qu'il y a toute une réflexion
aujourd'hui sur l'avenir de ce pôle
commercial qui doit être réaménagé alors
deuxième question on va aller loin on
retourne au siècle dernier retour en
1999 je vous propose de regarder ce
reportage réalisé à l'époque sur le
centre commercial de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines regardez
bonjour
comment vous le trouvez ce centre
commercial
on fait les courses au chaud il y a tout
ce qu'il faut
c'est bien pour moi personnellement je
trouve toujours tout ce que j'ai besoin
donc ça va quoi
quelques soit votre âge vous êtes plutôt
satisfait de votre centre commercial
régional et pourtant depuis un mois des
travaux sur la Place Colbert annoncent
de profonde modification et l'arrivée de
nouvelles enseignes le développement
aujourd'hui des centres commerciaux
passe par effectivement une offre
commerciale
minimum des enseignes attractives mais
nous essayons de faire en sorte que les
centres commerciaux deviennent également
de des centres de loisirs des centres de
vie
car le centre souffre d'un péché
originel il est sous-dimensionné pour
répondre à sa vocation régionale d'où
l'idée de l'étendre et d'attirer des
enseignes attractives le magasin H&M et
sa mode chic et pas cher sont de
celle-là il devrait ouvrir d'ici la fin
de l'année l'escalier d'accès au centre
sera supprimé et l'entrée par les
escalators améliorer ce n'est que la
première tranche des travaux côté avenue
du centre l'hypermarché devrait être
agrandi en raie de rue d'ici quelques
mois autres projets derrière le théâtre
une extension dédiée aux loisirs avec un
grand complexe cinéma multisol autant de
moyens de renforcer l'offre commerciale
alors à votre avis de quel projet parle
le journaliste de télé 78 de l'époque le
projet de la fin le projet de la fin mes
collègues
mais la médiathèque non
un projet d'espace de loisirs Skywest et
oui Grégory bravo c'est Skywest alors on
va voir la réponse s'afficher puis on va
commenter quand même ces images on voit
que l'avenue du centre finalement il n'y
a pas la grande enseigne de grandes
distribution il n'y a que le souterrain
il n'y avait pas l'espace à la surface
de l'avenue du centre tout est vide en
fait et finalement derrière
à côté du théâtre finalement il n'y
avait pas encore Skyway c'est pour ça
qu'on voyait cet espace vide parce que à
l'époque il n'y avait pas encore ben ce
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui Skywest
troisième question on poursuit donc le
quiz en 2012 avec ses nouvelles images
regardées réalisées à l'époque avec un
espace commercial assez végétalisé on
voit que c'est l'alpha marque 2
plusieurs centres commerciales assez
étendu alors est-ce que vous pouvez me
dire oui si tu es cette espèce
commerciale
[Musique]
bravo on va voir la réponse s'afficher
effectivement c'est au Clayes-sous-Bois
alors c'est vrai que c'était une
question assez simple mais on aurait pu
se trouver parce que c'est à la limite
avec plaisir donc on aurait pu aussi
avoir ce doute savoir si c'est plaisir
ou les clés sous bois on va passer à la
quatrième question regardez ces images
nous sommes au début des années 2000
alors c'est compliqué ou pas on va voir
il faut faire attention à l'ensemble des
détails à votre avis dans quel centre
commercial se déroule ces travaux qui
concernent un cinéma
regardez bien les images
ça ressemble à l'espace 50
Grégory encore une fois bon je sens que
Grégory va voir
effectivement bon on va voir la réponse
s'afficher c'est
50 ans et regarder bien les images avant
après c'est assez impressionnant
[Musique]
voilà concernant ces images ça fait
plaisir quand même de voir ces images du
passé voir comment c'est aujourd'hui et
ça date que du début du siècle actuel a
inventé siècle voilà alors question de
rapidité c'est assez simple franchement
le premier qu'il a là je vous donne
l'autorisation même si j'ai pas posé la
question vous pouvez y répondre regardez
ces images est-ce que vous pouvez me
dire dans quelles centres commerciales
on est ça a parlé de Mathilde bon il y a
même pas eu le temps n'a pas eu le temps
s'afficher on a et bien réponse en
images
centre commercial situé à au Chesnay au
Chesnay Rocancourt avec son copain et
son grand frère Vélizy 2 situé à Vélizy
2 allez dernière question un peu plus
compliqué celle-là regardez ces images
alors on a d'abord le centre commercial
mon grand mon beau Michelet pardon et
ensuite on va voir les images
du centre commercial mon grand plaisir
mais est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
alors c'est les deux centres commerciaux
qui sont sortis de terre c'est les deux
derniers est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
quel est l'entreprise qui a l'initiative
de ces deux projets
merci
non ce n'est pas une personne
l'entreprise à l'initiative des deux
projets mon beau Buchelay mon grand
plaisir
[Musique]
je la réponse est affiché dans les amis
est-ce qu'on peut remettre en question
la réponse tout de suite il s'agit en
fait de la compagnie de falsey voilà
donc à l'initiative de ces deux projets
de ces deux derniers centres commerciaux
qui sont sortis de terre dans les
Yvelines voilà bien merci beaucoup
Nicolas dandry à chaque quiz on en
apprend un peu plus sur l'histoire des
Yvelines Merci à VOUS ils ont Grégory
grand vainqueur quand même Grégory
vainqueur cette semaine c'est bientôt la
fin de cette émission mais juste avant
de se quitter je vous propose de
regarder la météo de demain
demain matin le ciel devrait être encore
au bien nuageux sur l'ensemble du
département au niveau des températures
il fera moins 1 degré avec des ressentis
d'environ moins 3 degrés dans
l'après-midi le ciel devrait se dégager
nous devrions avoir quelques éclaircies
au niveau des températures comptées 2
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et
Versailles et 1 degré à Rambouillet et
pour ce week-end quel temps fera-t-il
Gabriel et bien Mathilde la tendance
reste la même samedi matin les
températures seront négatives sur
l'ensemble du département entraînant du
givre à certains endroits comptez 1
degré à Versailles et jusqu'à moins de
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et Rambouillet
l'après-midi le soleil fera son
apparition les températures seront
comprises entre deux et trois degrés
dimanche la tendance reste la même avec
des températures comprises cette fois
entre -1 et 0° prévoyait des averses sur
le nord du département l'après-midi des
éclaircies sont à prévoir il fera 1
degré à Versailles Rambouillet et Houdan
les températures atteindra dont les deux
degrés avant de la jolie merci beaucoup
Gabriel Gontier c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]